and finally new rule that Donald Trump
keeps insisting that he's the least
racist person anyone has ever met he has
to explain why the single most
consistent thing in his whole life is he
loves to pick fights with black people
of all this myriad insanities if I had
to pick one line for his tombstone it
would be here lies Donald Trump picked
fights with black baby I mean really
think of the list Colin Kaepernick levar
ball Barack Obama Eric Holder the war
Widow from the failed raid in Nigeria
were widows congresswoman the Central
Park five Steph Curry the UCLA
basketball players arrested in China
will be Goldberg April Ryan the entire
NFL the cast of Hamilton the city of
Atlanta falling apart
Chicago disaster Nigeria they live in
huts Haiti they all have AIDS and the
entire continent of Africa a [ __ ]
Charlotte's Ville Mary find people on
both sides would be a joke against Trump
I could continue this list but we'd be
here through the end of February which
is Black History Month or as Trump likes
to say all months matter it's a just a
coincidence that he's perpetually pissed
off at the NBA in the NFL but golfers
and hockey players never seem to bother
him on the country he once tweeted a
fact golfers don't get aches and pains
like others who don't golf it's
amazingly remedial
but then his entire presidency is
amazingly remedial the New York Times
reports that Trump hate watches CNN to
get worked up especially Don Lemon ha of
all CNN's anchors what could it possibly
be about Don Lemon that incenses in the
most as of today Trump has tweeted about
Obama 2599 times just his tweets on
Obama being a Kenyan who cheated his way
into college could fill a book a book
entitled are you there god it's me
dumbass
[Applause]
colin kaepernick is the son of a [ __ ]
so is Marshawn Lynch and all the black
NFL players who take a name because
they're very ungrateful kind of a theme
with Trump ungrateful Steph Curry
ungrateful yes because he hesitated on
going to the White House so Trump took
back the invitation he never sent just
someone who didn't want to go then there
were the three UCLA basketball players
who got caught shoplifting in China
finally something Trump could relate to
stealing but but were they grateful no
Trump tweeted to to lift them in jail
because even though they thanked him it
wasn't really from the heart guys you
want to see how it's done I'll show you
how it's done
exquisite presidential leadership you're
one heck of a leader Thank You president
Trump for allowing us to have you as our
president
that's that's how mr. Trump likes his
ass kissed but here's the problem mr.
president by our calculations you're
going to completely run out of black
people - of a contrived feud with by the
fall of 2019 you'll be down to the
wu-tang clan faint Famous Amos and mr. T
so I was thinking who could you hate
almost as much and then it dawned on me
there is one white person you loved
above all others only Rosie O'Donnell
that's right you really really really
hate Rosie O'Donnell and I'd look it
right in that fat ugly face of hers and
said Rosie you're fired so there we have
it
hate the Irish
it's xenophobia classic and it's
actually pretty easy to do you think
Kanye is a pain in the ass I've ever met
bono oh there's plenty of us Irish types
you can fume about for example get
irrationally obsessed about Liam Neeson
taken yeah that's what I feel like after
I spend 12 BOTS on one of your movies
Colin Farrell why do you keep working
you made more bombs in the IRA and you
sound like the ocean is dying
saoirse ronan i like actresses with
normal names like storming so what
you're 22 we could do a perfect American
accent Milani he's been in since 96 if
he still sounds like Bela Lugosi
Blanco hideous frog Conor McGregor you
had one job beating the [ __ ] out of a
black guy you let us all down sad Ronald
Reagan what's with the crazy makeup and
hair you're the president try not to
look like a clown
no more hay toka hunters
how come you're always in handling when
what you do mostly is blow no Ranga tag
no orangutan you're the orangutan
[Applause]